Round of Applause for me also major uh
bonehead move
uh I don't go to the bank too often
because a lot of this stuff gets wired
right because you know
paper gets heavy
but uh we we
um
I went to the bank and I put it in my
Google my Google uh directions or
whatever it's called
and guess what happened dude a Wells
Fargo came up
and I go great on Santa Monica Boulevard
that's where I go all good I know the
dudes there I know the homies and I know
that
speaking of money I just made sixty
dollars on Shopify but
um
yeah dude and it's like so I I plug it
in and I'm going down to go to Santa
Monica
the the the the the the street
and I'm like it says take left and I'm
like that's but that's not where it is I
go I'm like all right let's just see
what they do I take sometimes they say
like well as far they pretend like if
you do it in the Google thing Maps it'll
go in and then it's just like a a
[ __ ] uh what do you call it um first
swear word five thirty minutes in
um it's a uh uh [ __ ] what do you call
ATM and you're like oh for [ __ ] sake
you ever do that you put it in the bank
and you're like oh Bank of America and
you go and it's just an ATM and you're
like I wanted to go in so dude they
should specify on the Google but again I
digress and so
um so I get there and it's a whole full
Bank dude and it was closer than the one
that I've been going to for years so oh
dude what a big bonehead move
and I'm pissed but it's okay because
we're stacking yape right so I go in and
the [ __ ] bank the new bank that I'm
gonna go to this is not my home Bank
dude oh it's much closer than the last
one and yeah like the guy who deals with
my [ __ ] he emails me from time to time
you know he's like you want to go over
some more interest rates or whatever
they say I don't listen to the email but
I I always reply back like yeah whatever
my business manager says buddy good
seeing you the other day
but they got a whole bank that I didn't
know about a whole bank that I didn't
know about and so I go in and when I go
in what's it smell like it smells like
eggs and pipes
[Music]
dude it smells like [ __ ] eggs and
pipes dude
and you know what I'm talking about too
that's the greatest thing smells like
eggs and pipes and so I go there
because this is not my home Bank
and guess what it's next to a [ __ ]
coffee shop Jesus Christ
[Applause]
[Music]
so I'm just like in heaven do it and
it's near a Trader Joe's but it's all
good because I don't go to Trader Joe's
nor do I grocery shop but the talent
there and the chicks that go there the
eye candy it's ridiculous
but your boy's just looking nowadays
right he's just looking he's like that
emoji like this
but he just looks but it's all good I'm
Not Dead
one time when I was a kid I asked my dad
I said when do you want to stop like
sleeping with other women and he laughed
like hell and he said well I I don't I
mean like I don't know you always want
to and I said really and he said yeah
I'm not dead oh we were at the Dodger
game the memories
but um
so anyway uh I go into the bank and um
and uh smells like eggs and farts and
[ __ ] pipes and [ __ ] sewer sewer
sewage
and uh I'm doing the bank and I'm there
for way too long and it's and it's too
it's too so I'm in LA on the next in
line I'm waiting too long and already
I'm like pissed off at my new home bank
and then it's my turn and I go in and I
have two checks I have a personal check
and then I have a business check all
right
I do the personal check and they make me
sign in four different times okay so I'm
I say what's going on is everything cool
and they're like yeah sorry it's just we
got the account number wrong and we got
to write a new thing so sign this so I
signed that then
they try to put my business check in
they they give me something to sign
again I sign it they they they try to do
it then I have to sign something else
again and I say is everything okay and
they say yes and then the lady comes
over and this is 25 minutes in I'm
dealing I'm standing at this [ __ ]
whatever it is with the bulletproof
glass and I'm waiting
and this lady walks in and she says hold
on I wrote it down quote quote I wrote a
done quote she walked in just like this
super sassy beautiful lady like walked
in like you know with big hoop earrings
and I'm not you know I don't want to you
can get in a lot of trouble saying
somebody's race but you know what race
she was just because of the hoop
earrings right well I guess you could
have been Mexican but she wasn't so now
you know what she is and so uh this is
what she said hold on she walked in and
it was just I was getting so riled up
and then because it took so long and
then she goes like this
oh what is this smell it's funky in here
y'all
accident she says oh what is this smell
that's funky in here y'all and I looked
at her and I go yeah and then she walked
by me and she said to the [ __ ] guy
behind the counter he says
are you guys she says are you guys about
the sewer
just so great she says what's what's
this smell
that she said to she after she said oh
what's the smell is funky in here y'all
she arrived at the thing and she said
what's the smell what's the smell it's
stink up in here y'all imma buy y'all
some Lysol and I'm just finally dude she
came to my rescue so thank you lady
you've got big hook bearings but you
came to my hero appearance were so big
if she was sit in front of me in the
movie theater I have to watch watch the
movie thrown
um
but yeah do it
I just tank up in here y'all
so I was pissed and then she came in and
saved the day and light in my move you
know what it is dude I'm my [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I'm not bipolar so chill with the
comments dude you'll guys you know
everyone's always trying to diagnose
like somebody's like oh Crystal you're
the first guy who's addicted to CBD I'm
not addicted to CBD you can't get
addicted to CBD but I love CBD dude and
I'm with that pure spectrum and if you
want it dude I eat those gummies those
gummies are ridiculous I put the dropper
under my tongue and I'd let it sit for
30 minutes for 30 minutes 30 seconds and
I just [ __ ] you know I let it
ruminate and [ __ ] you know I'm just
like I put the drop in and then I'm like
that top note
and it chills me out dude and did have I
had restless leg syndrome since I've
taken the pure Spectrum D CBD and the
answer is absolutely no I haven't dude
so it's working and if you want to get
it the links Below in the show note
description and you can get 10 off by
typing in congrats yes dude and I'm
doing that because you know I started
taking it I like it and I wanted to
partner with me and you know
so get 10 off actually no you know what
they're doing 20 off this weekend I
believe Jenny we go check it out
um but uh yeah so
uh
uh so yeah I do but my mood is very
chill but let's get off the CBD talk but
my I'm too uh uh in my life I have been
in the past two back and forth with my
emotions like something smells bad I'm
pissed off I walk outside it's a
beautiful day and then I drop that and
then I'm feeling good all of a sudden I
gotta let's I gotta be more Zen you know
crazy crazy
[Music]
congratulations crazy